[Music]
did you watch the couch guy [ __ ] on tick
tock
yeah who gives a [ __ ]
it's funny but like they are like
literal teenagers they just got out of
high school like that's why he's [ __ ]
awkward yeah i think he was about to
smash like this is the the creator of
the video the girl yeah she said she
commented breaks my heart that people
can watch a special moment and bring so
much negativity this is special yeah
dude i saw some one of the comments
further down is like i think if 30
million people agree on something and
you're the only one that disagrees yeah
probably means you're not right but i
mean her dude made a tick tock
[Music]
and
[Music]
i was like you know stop snitching on me
yeah basically like he's like you guys
stop doing that [ __ ] he's like i love
lauren you guys are being weird and like
even if she walked in and that dude was
nailing someone that's secretly what
everyone was hoping for yeah like
everyone's engaging this because they
they like that these two people have
like some type of trauma you know if
this [ __ ] was just like surprising my
boyfriend he was like yay there wouldn't
be 30 million people being like oh
that's cute yeah it'd be five i just
wonder if there's something to like how
how many people attach onto this small
insignificant [ __ ] like why why is this
so weirdly engaging like analyzing this
video or or like analyzing the gabby
potato case obviously that's a little
bit more
like emotionally charged because i feel
like this one is like she died but like
why do people on tik tok feel like it's
their
prerogative to get super involved in
this and like be obsessed with it yeah
it's also an easy thing to have an
opinion about this is just everyone
seeing like all the engagement that gaby
potato [ __ ] got so this is their way of
like trying to like i'm not gonna miss
it this time yeah yeah a little bit of
controversy here i'm getting in right
getting my likes
i do like the parodies of this though
the parodies are really funny yeah super
funny this is like so rough because this
girl's just exposed herself to all kinds
of criticism and [ __ ] overnight and then
everyone will walk away and live their
life and she will just forever be
perpetually having arguments in her head
in the shower just reading those
comments no cause listen cause
a year from now she's gonna be
inscribing on the walls the phone passed
peeing on her feet the sneaky phone pass
if he was actually passing his phone
yeah he's sitting in a cage in the
corner i was not passing myself
[Music]
yeah sure [ __ ] it
here it is
[Music]
can we just not show that clip and just
focus on cody doing this tick tock dance
yeah i was lip syncing it
there there are a couple sounds going on
tick tock right now that i it needs to
stop there's so many
the killers
oh that one should
burn in hell dude and here's the thing
the original video of that but people
were making the harmonies that's cool
yeah it's that stupid trend of people
telling stories over and they take 9 000
hours it's so it's always like the
payoff isn't that good no it's not you
know you know what i hate ah this makes
my [ __ ] blood boil when someone does
one of those someone leaves a comment
and it's like wait i need the full story
and they reply to that comment and they
go tune in tomorrow for a live
oh yeah
yeah
we don't [ __ ] care
no make the follow up 15 seconds and
just take that yeah okay we don't
[ __ ] care no one wants to watch you
live be like
so it started when i was nine
not important yeah did he cheat on you
or not yeah yep
let me know if i'm wrong here i might be
in the wrong with this one you're
definitely not but okay so there was one
i could be brown i could be yeah watch
that was pretty good it was the lady on
shark tank okay and uh the way that
story went is that she met this guy
she married them they started a business
together i think they were both they
both came from nothing yeah they started
this business together they grew it she
or she worked at a restaurant and she
met him he was basically i think he'll
be good at real estate somehow so they
started dating they got married they
started a real estate brokerage firm
together they grew it to be one of the
top
in new york and then she left he left
her
for her
assistant
was like i'm leaving
got married and he basically said uh
they split the business in half and he
was like
you'll never succeed without me
and like 10 years later he went bankrupt
and she grew to be the top real estate
brokerage firm
and then she sold it for 66 million
dollars that one i was like [ __ ] that
was a good payoff right good okay so
this other one i watched made the
mistake of watching is this woman and
she basically says uh i met this guy
three years ago and we started dating
and all of a sudden one day i just
didn't hear from him or he disappeared
and i was like
holy [ __ ] okay it's about to get intense
right and she was like it turns out he
just lied about his identity and then
basically ghosted me and then i tried to
talk about it online and i got a cease
and desist from his lawyer and now i
feel really manipulated and controlled
but i'm speaking my truth that was the
end and i was like i mean i understand
that he lied but it kind of sounds like
he just got dumped in a bad way yeah i
saw that one i dug deep on that one
that woman seems like
she's
like she's
still believes in magic you know like
okay
like
what do you mean like that's like
it's the only way i could describe it
you know to be fair it's a phrase i use
kind of regularly now but it's like
she's that type of person
you know
a cease and desist
how do you get cease and desisted for
discussing something publicly to believe
that
it's unfortunate she must have had a
childhood where she that makes her prone
to that type of thing yeah i think the
dude was gaming i don't think that guy
is like scott free i don't think he just
like bailed i think he probably was
being a dirty two-timer yeah i mean i
just don't think it's a i could be brown
i could be blue no for sure yeah it's
not one of those stories yeah it's not
one of those stories because i'm sorry
dude are you are you gatekeeping i could
be brown i could be blue yes i am i am
because at the end you're supposed to be
like oh
what yeah i agree when the harmony
[ __ ] kicks yeah yeah you're supposed
to be like i could be brown i could be
yeah no way but that story was like the
end was like so i'm speaking my truth
and it's like about what you got dumped
and the guy lied to you about his
identity like
yeah
and all the comments were like this has
happened to me too this happened to me
too this happened to me too and i was
like well it's cause it's not a i could
be brown i could be blue story
that is true i could be brown the guy's
a dick don't get me wrong that's a
[ __ ] dick thing to do yeah i could be
brown i could be a blue story but he
lied and then he broke up with you and
ghosted you like that happens no one
should be able to comment oh this
happened to me too
exactly then it's not i could be brownie
blue yeah there was another one this guy
this is another example of a good one
yeah this guy
said that he
was walking to his car one day realized
he was getting followed
and then he wakes up in the hospital
like months later
got stabbed by the guy that was
following him like 67 times lived
woke up from a coma and now he's like
piecing together everything that
happened and trying to restart his life
i was like holy [ __ ] yeah i could be
brown i could be blue the only comment
the only top comment there
should be i'm the one who stabbed you
and you have to you have to remember
like when you go post your traumas on
tick tock you have to remember there's a
there's a broad spectrum of trauma to
compare you know we've already been
exposed to all kinds of [ __ ] see that's
the thing that's that's the real issue
with social media is now we've gotten so
comfortable comparing trauma you got
ghosted you're about a guy got stabbed
67 times yeah yeah yeah maybe work on
your set yeah and come up with a few
tags
come back
uh you'll knock it out the park next
yeah but like you need a better closer
yeah speaking my truth is speaking your
truth not a great punchline yeah it's
not dude we should do america's got
talent but america's got trauma and it's
people telling their stories and we're
just like
oh my god that was
everyone in this room is [ __ ] crying
that was amazing thank you for sharing
that or
the middle of the story so he yeah so
then he i never heard from him again
that's it he just ghosted you is he
still in here has been ghosted by by
someone before everyone's like no i have
so that's all i got to say oh my god
dude someone share some horrible trauma
then it's simon paula
and randy and they're like come here
come here come here golden ticket
and they all do that
i forgot about that
damn damn some weird [ __ ] used to happen
on those shows my my dad locked me in a
basement and i didn't see light for 25
years
come here come here you're gonna be a
star wow wow that was moving
kiss him as well on the lips on the lips
too last is simon comey that was the
worst trauma story i've ever had he's
like being all dick your trauma
is so
pedestrian
what
everyone
everyone has been verbally assaulted yes
not interesting
jesus christ
you